it is a farewell and it is a hello as in
hello Sims hello Slavko and farewell to
the studio oh yeah
well we're gonna be in the studio you're
saying it's gonna be better it's gonna
be better right all right little
scheduling note for all the Sims and
left go faithful Monday we are going to
have a fan mail bag episode and it's
gonna be amazing we've already had like
400 emails and tweets and DMS and all
that stuff out of here okay okay are we
allowed to take a day all we're taking a
vacation so there's only gonna be one
podcast next week okay I hope that's
okay with all our listeners and so that
will be in the same setup and then when
the putt time we get back Monday the
23rd this entire room is gonna look
different so all the commenters that are
like I like the other studio ah it's
gonna be different there's gonna be wood
there's gonna be pictures and all the
funds that define Sims and left go
around us but we need a little vacation
yeah I'd like one I'm really pumped whoa
big vacation yeah I want to give a
special shout out to Eli Manning and to
the episode I have an interview with Eli
Manning one of the quotes already all
over the place I mean Rick espn's
motioned to me when as soon as he said
it and you were like this is gonna be
awesome that he said that I have no feel
for that stuff and it worked and it
definitely heal i Manning just saying
talking about sake wands legs and asses
saying look I don't often stare at men's
legs but I kind of can't help myself or
I can I can share his passion hi I told
him that you complement him as the
Giants he has the response is best
quarterback of all time he responds to
that I even talked about our super whoa
big offseason man Davis Webb and he's
got a really good story about that so
that's at the end of the episode stay
tuned ten minute convo brought to you by
Gatorland I want to give him there to
stare at men's legs and ass but it's not
not with him now I used to be like that
would Derek Brooks a little now I'm
gonna lie just look at his body his
upper body wasn't that impressive but
the lower body was like so unbelievable
I was just like damn every day there's a
video of sake one's a workouts that
comes out and I go this isn't normal
like you're taking a squat rack with
with a hundred eighty pounds on it
uphill then you're explode
it's as Eli says in the interview I want
to see him in pads and that's what I'm
gonna get really excited but he's the
ultimate whoa offseason body ultimate
and to add to that just like come on
look look let's let's talk about our guy
o our guys being a leader and other guys
are there I mean you know yeah the guy
that's a misfit this this horrible
person and dumps - OH - he's not
dedicated to football not this guy that
just everyday puts out also a video of
him working out yes it has all the star
players wanting to come work out with
him so yeah you just got named most
stylist athlete of the year I can
believe that yeah yeah I mean he's
pretty stylish he's I mean I couldn't
pull off fashion is funny like sometimes
we just wear crazy clothes are like
you're fashionable and it's like he wore
a pink hoodie with like mismatching
sneakers and now I'm just kidding he's
got it all though over the top it's like
cool cool fast never seems like he's
trying too hard
wherever I want to give a huge shout out
right now to the listeners that are on
the reddit page that have created
something that you've taken something
that we didn't even bring up and now
it's getting to another level yeah this
Sims and left go fantasy league ventric
has been updating about what's happening
so apparently shout-out to meatloaf
Henry and whoever else is on the reddit
page making this happen so many of you
guys but they started a fantasy league
and a lot of people wanted to help so
then they made us a second fantasy
league then they made a third then they
made a fourth amazing they've now had to
make five fantasy leagues and they're
creating something called the SL FL in
which all of the leagues will have the
same rules and they will create a super
tournament of champions at the end where
the best teams will go for the one crown
as the ultimate SL FL I'd like to get
this up to like 12 leagues like I'd like
to keep me amazing so whoever wins I
think deserves to get on the podcast and
we do a full interview and I found their
strategy of what they did all year and I
say we give them some signed swag some
signed walking off season shirts all
that but I do maybe come on the podcast
and write you know biggest blowouts of
the week we could just give like a
little shout outs will give shoutouts
and updates on yes things that caught
our eye somewhat like it someone sent me
here's the first matchup -
teams one of them is Sims spleen and the
other team is say quads Berkeley so big
matchup in week one big match you guys
are crazy and we appreciate it and we
love you and your awesome really
speaking of Eli man and we brought him
up earlier he was ranked in Madden as
the 36th best quarterback in the game
yeah and you had him at 38 right so
apparently you're not that crazy but at
the same point I I don't know Madden's
ratings think towards you out for your
running back rankings I was like get out
of it what do we know what their running
back rankings I was like on nfl.com if
you want to look I feel like I saw
earlier I didn't read the article by
running back over I Kings for everybody
who feel good about it well the more I
thought about it the more I do feel good
about it
yes I do think Todd Gurley is the best
running back in football right now I
think with the past game run game combo
Ezekiel Elliott you know hey last year
was a weird year he's still young and in
his prime and he had to deal with a lot
of court stuff and off the field stuff
so that are the guy I got it okay and
then three David Johnson for loving
embel five Devonta Freeman I do I feel
good about that they're number one is
levy on right there number two is David
Johnson they're number three is Zeke
they're number four is girly and they're
number five is Freeman okay see you have
the same time five they just switched
girly and levy on and David Johnson and
Zeke's I mean listen that's certain
certainly arguable or yeah arguable I
just look at David Johnson and Zika
where they are in their career and levy
on the fact that he's he's been hurt and
where he is in his career he's not as
explosive as those guys that are on that
list
Le'Veon Bell is not the kind of guy
that's gonna catch a screen at his own
30 yard line and go 70 yards for a
touchdown where I think all these other
guys are that now he's a little bit more
of a consistent find something when
nothing's there he's a credible route
route runner and receiver but there are
some of these other guys on the list I
just jumped fentruck who can't make it
today because he's so busy doing
everything he just sent me a screenshot
so ESPN took our sake Wong quote yeah
and put it up and Stephen a Smith
comment and under it so Stephen a Smith
is reacting to our quote and he says
sake
as a physical freak he's something
special but what it will mean if Eli
isn't special that offensive line
continues to be what it's been right
okay Thank You Steven a for that serious
analysis after Eli talking about his
legs he always has to have a hot take I
can't we just sit and marvel at a guy's
legs why does it have to be those legs
they might not be running they might not
be running anywhere well that I was
alive any good was not bad that's not
bad I like Stephen a does so I do too I
have no problem with any of this really
funny I realized that I like Stephen a
once skip was gone yes Stephen a as I
mastered a when skip was there too
because he's the only one with brains on
the show Stephen a is able to yell and
say words that I have to look up on
dictionary.com yeah for like two minutes
in a row it is a skill oh here is a huge
government or there's some smart dudes
yeah and yeah I've respected even a I
really do because I I think he's just I
mean he's a die-hard sports fan you can
tell he loves it he's thought about it
he doesn't yeah you know and I do I even
when I see him around New York City he's
a cool dude man you see him around New
York City like random crap like him
getting his car washed and I was like
walking by the carwash and he was there
like you definitely said something you
know so do you go up to him I'm just
like what up Steve today I think he
looks at me he's like who's this crazy
white guy and I go it zooms and he's
like oh yeah you guys talking about me
just say hi whatever it was that's it's
quick but do you compliment them usually
compliments well I don't know I you know
you're the man that's if I like you
that's yeah you're the man yeah I did it
you're the man to Lennox Lewis one time
and he really appreciate it yeah because
we were like a fashion show and it was
like me him and like six-foot skinny
women and no one knew who he was I was
like you know you demand here I
appreciate it like don't punch me in the
chest all right got that one now if you
like it a little bit more serious this
is pissed
Kyle Shanahan
favorite coach in the NFL the
soundboards amazing so Kyle Shanahan
amendment number two yes but it's not
Kyle Shanahan I was gonna say where are
we coming up with news with Kyle here
it's actually as defensive coordinator
Robert Saleh okay
and he was talked I'm sure the Niners
are being asked you guys finished the
season really well how can that
crossover and he said look when you're
trying to make the jump first half of
the year it's a beast you're gonna win
some you shouldn't you're gonna lose
some you should but then he says this
about the Niners if we are sitting at
four and four don't be surprised but the
run is going to happen there's no doubt
in my mind that the end of season run is
gonna happen it's just about how quickly
we can get that run started right what
do you think about I do think it's a
very fair assessment I think everybody
is a little too high and hot on the
49ers I would agree to you know I mean
people are expecting 9 1 9 win seasons 8
10 win seasons possible playoff team I
don't look at their roster as being that
caliber especially in depth right so I
look at their coaching staff as being
pretty special though
and I think what he's saying is yeah
they can get on a run first of all they
have tremendous self belief because of
the way the season ended last year we
know that that offense can get high and
and really left co you and I know this
and this is listen my friend Kyle
Shannon he might not like did I say this
but I'm gonna say it anyways they
wouldn't they weren't an Owen ten
football team last year they had a
quarterback that was young and
inexperienced and in my opinion over
drafted and I've told Colin the
quarterback right I mean he would have
been like he wasn't even in the top 70
no he was in the top 70 he was where he
was yeah he was yeah but the the the
thing I looked at with that is yes they
had an inexperienced quarterback who was
young who I think was hair overdrafted
like I said and I think that cost them
the opportunity to win a few football
games those close football team amazing
to take in our betting last year because
because they were like oh and six the
lines were huge but they were able to
stay in all the games but it was like a
quarterback turnover at the end that
always ruined right exactly
I think the reason he's doing this is a
great coaching maneuver if you say we're
going to finish next year strong I Gary
t it it's it means that you can mess up
in the beginning of the year pressure
your team doesn't get down because then
you go look I said this was gonna happen
it's the second half that matters
always undersell the first half that way
you can build in the second if good
coach a good coach speak or something to
that and he knows his team's you know
listen to those types of things and it's
it's teaching a young team to go don't
lose confidence early on in the year and
things don't go as they're will get it
straight at some point and get hot and
get on that row because they're gonna be
getting gassed up all offseason I
realized I need to say this for Odell
since we're not gonna be back in person
till the 23rd I will have actually
already passed my baby due date for
Odell I will say this now about a
hundred people have already been
eliminated we're in 400 guesses for the
Odell including Giacomo D Gaspari who
said big offseason for Simms left go and
Kevin pana who said 2019 draft party
extraordinaire we're getting close so
we'll see if Odell gets that contract
but you're still in at July 28th yep and
we'll see when he gets that money I look
I'll look at Odell Beckham jr. one
similar way to I look at Rob Gronkowski
I still think they're trade bait and I
will not be so I saw this story that was
until Gronk gets his contract extension
he could still be traded so you think
Odell and Gronk can still be trade I do
I do
I think that's still it's gonna be a
real likelihood of that happening as
well I think they're I think I think
it's low on both like I would put let's
just say if we went out of a hundred
percent I'm gonna say it's like around
25-30 percent who gets more was a higher
percentage of being true I think
Gronkowski would be a higher percentage
of being traded because I just think
that would be such a typical it's really
be the smart football decision in a lot
of ways a Qaeda and that's getting to
the end of his career a lot of baggage
playing good right he's had back forearm
he's got steel plates all over his body
and he's still great but his name is
even bigger than his value then then
maybe that they even should just because
he's still such a big name would you
agree with this yeah Odell would get you
more yeah but the value that you would
get back for Gronk would be better
because you don't really want to give up
Odell they say that again you would get
more for Odell but that's also because
he's a better player
yes you get better value for Gronk
because you know in your heart of hearts
he's got like two years left exact maybe
one yeah really I don't think it's one I
mean if he can do the same if he was
kind of Superbowl right right I know I
know so hopefully that would not be the
case but yes I mean if Gronk decides he
wants to play football I still think
he's got two or three years of really
dominant play which teams would trade
for Krunk
but Texans I think the Texans would
certainly be in that get any team with
like former like Vrabel like the Titans
I would think they would know the title
a position they're not gonna be they're
not gonna be worried about that okay you
know do a team like the Chargers who
feel like they're on the cusp when they
make that type of move I've heard people
like people say that the 49ers might
have been interested in Gronk way back
when who you would know I don't think so
I just no I wouldn't think so none of
that I've even had that conversation
with Kyle but I don't think Kyle kind of
I don't think he would put the value I
mean we know how awesome he is I don't
think he would put the value and that
kind of guy and that money happy new
young Titans are super athletic exactly
right so and Kyle can scheme up guys to
be better than they are exactly where
the Chargers are gonna be like we're
gonna pound your face right and we need
that tight end when the matches match up
exactly yes so I do I look at the team
you said 25 to 30 percent is pretty damn
likely much is the Giants and Eli's
telling you how amazing sterling
Shepherds been and everybody's been
telling me about Evan Engram and how
good he's gonna be when I hear little
things like that that and there's no
deal done and it doesn't sound like
there's any been progress been made and
I did ask about Odell in that interview
yeah and I've avoided it right a little
bit right
I just asked where would you rank um
all-time and he was kind of like you
know the talents there just got to get
him out there but he was definitely not
as excited about him I mean that would
be a little bit alarming to me Wow
so let's say right now does it happen
either of them put your Sims - I'm gonna
say no I'm gonna say no it does not
happen but I do think they're gonna
we're gonna hear another rumor or two
about it when training camp starts this
is not gonna go away with Odell until he
gets this deal because I still think
there's gonna tee times across the
morning it is very interesting - now
that the thing that New England's gonna
be hard is did the thing but we've heard
with like Brady getting involved with
that conversation
that's where there could be a load L
doesn't really have a safety net Gronk
has Tom Brady who at this point it's
like heist Belichick the number-two guy
under Kraft
right and he's gonna go mr. Kraft II
can't take my lifeline away in Rob
Gronkowski and that'll be my call for
four weeks I have two years left which I
think could end a conversation too with
the the fact that Edelman is not there
for four games this is a one thing some
of the fans got upset about you
dismissing Mariota throwing more
interceptions and touchdowns mainly
saying that statistic come on you guys
are so good taking that statistic isn't
a good indicator but this is a comment
from DeMarco Murray on Mariota that was
interesting to me he said a lot of guys
in the locker room loved my fingers on
chef ders podcast they respect him and
we knew that yeah it's hard not to love
and respect Mariota he's a great guy
that is one of those guys where you go
what's your hobby football what's your
love football what's your daughter's
name football like you just see it yeah
but he did say if he can really just be
more vocal and take charge of that
offense I think he's gonna be great
we noticed towards the end of the year
he started standing over guys his
performance in the Chiefs game so much
energy do you think he will be more
vocal this year I do will the for help
bring that out in him yes well I think
what's gonna help you know not only do I
think guys like Vrabel and Lafleur gonna
bring it out of him just with their
social skills but with the number one
thing what's gonna bring it out what
makes you a leader when you start the
ball on the field so right you catch
watched as a leader this year because it
was twenty eight and seven right so that
gives you the confidence and it also
gives the team the confidence in you to
go he's our guy this is our guy yeah I
don't think I think everybody sees that
potential in Mariota I don't think he is
that guy yet and listen I'm not trying I
wasn't trying to be mean to Marcus
Mariano again I feel like it's my duty
to speak truths and put things into
context there's great potential he can
be a superstar and he's done a lot of
good things already but I'm just saying
I was just trying to point out that the
Mariota thing has not been this
squeaky-clean either he's great more the
better person off that I'm just going to
talk to you as a friend yes we witnessed
what happened to Mike Lombardi when he
made those comments about Doug Peterson
I would not talk [ __ ] about any
quarterback that is in a system that
comes from the Kyle Shanahan tree Sean
McVeigh Matt Lafleur we've seen what
could be available like we see how
people can't be like right about like
they can't be sensible about Jared Goff
because they can't like separate Sean
McVeigh from Jared Goff and that Todd
Gurley was a leading receiver on the
team
what do you mean Jared Goff the eighth
best quarterback he's not he's just not
back off I could see that happening to
Mariota this year also when you mix in a
Dion Lewis with Henry with an offensive
line that comes back super healthy with
that system I'm not betting against
Mariota because it might not even be
Mariota yeah it might just be that damn
since no doubt about it I mean he's
gonna have a friend I I hear you don't
take this I'm not taking the stance hard
all I'm trying to do is just pump
everybody's brakes and the fact that oh
you know now that Jameis has become a
disaster off the field everybody
Oh Mariota was the guy all along I'm
just saying slow down with that Mariota
has had to turnover issues as well in
his career yes that's all I was trying
to point out not trying to hate on him
enough but you know like listen you know
we've seen the year before 2016 yeah he
had a better year throwing the football
he had nine interceptions he lost five
Thumba light right no that was before
last year the year before that I'm just
gonna give a little more context okay it
was 19 touchdowns 10 interceptions 6
lost fumbles so not all of those are on
him but there was a good amount that
were because of him carrying the ball he
was a little loose with other times he's
admitted to that that's all I was trying
to say no yeah
hi drew cheers bright from Mariota I
bring it up because I want you to add
clarification yes thank you I think
sometimes I think sometimes people like
take one statement and then they run
with it you're like I didn't even say
that so let's get to a little bit of
news first
the the new owner of the Carolina
Panthers is officially sworn-in Dave
pepper and he cannot remove Jerry
Richardson statue because he's
contractually obligated to leave it like
it is it made me think of like billions
and like house of cards and all these
things were like there's a rich person
that's like I'll give you the team but
you can't do this like it really feels
like a like an under-the-table deal but
Oh Jerry Richardson got in trouble for
all that stuff had to pay millions of
dollars to the NFL got into some legal
trouble too but the statue stays up but
that just felt like some billion [ __ ] to
me it's what you're I mean he's a power
player yeah it is some billions shake
and you know what when I watch workplace
misconduct oh it doesn't matter but yeah
we've got a lot of leave they brought
the team here so we'll leave a statue it
just feels like they can pay their way
out of anything and you know what else
felt like a billions guy when I was
watching that all-or-nothing Cowboys
thing Jerry Jones getting into the Hall
of Fame Clair Jerry Jones to the Hall of
Fame felt like he was like now I've done
a lot for this league and I have a lot
of money and I could pill it out I can't
support Roger Goodell but you better put
me in the Hall of Fame before I pass
away owners and the NFL Hall of Fame is
one of the biggest jokes to me in sports
oh you mean they contributed to the NFL
to protect their billion dollar
investments well what what good Souls
they have I mean come on how much more
do we have to give the billionaire I
mean there are already experts at
everything and they own the team and now
they want to gold bronze bust in the
Hall of Fame like get the hell out of
here with that you've had enough
privileges in life sorry I think the
original noise the Rooneys and the Hunts
and those guys like the construct of the
league yeah but like if you're gonna
celebrate Jerry Jones and Bob Kraft for
bringing in like TV deals then I'm just
gonna say no the the interest of the NFL
is what caused the numbers to be so high
it's it's ridiculous and they get credit
for high it's like the CEO they've hit
credit cuz that the company did well
it's like yeah but the company was
already doing well when they got it
exactly but like Al Davis like helping
merge the AFL in the NFL like yes that's
a different class yes yes that day is
gone with the Bears it's a machine that
rolls itself now I mean yeah I mean we
don't need like okay yeah I understand
he's done some good things for the
league and all that but it's not like
this league wouldn't be here without
Jerry Jones Tepper is also part of our
whoa big offseason that's right three of
them talking about head coach Ron Rivera
he says I think run Ron is a natural
defensive guy just a natural natural
like walking down the street and
drinking water just natural how often do
you walk down the street and drink water
not often I'm not walking
treat me like now it's hard to walk and
drink water especially in a cup - it'll
spill on your shirt I find that I have
to stop what you have this stop
it's almost unnatural Street a squeeze
bottle I mean that's one one thing yes
then you end up like but they III hear
you he is a natural that even side of
the ball I will say no man I mean he's
the man I think about those old Eagles
teams I mean Ron Rivera was the
linebackers coach yeah I forgot about
that I know I'm chargers that's like
when I think when he was there with
north turner and he was the d
coordinator there I was with Denver one
year and we had to play them yeah always
with the Eagles emphasis saying the
special teams coordinator was Harbaugh
for that team they had so many guys on
that staff threw a wild alright next
whoa whoa big offseason a future
hall-of-famer calling another player the
best one of the best of the game yes
Andre Johnson said I definitely think
DeAndre Hopkins he's arguably the best
in the game he finally has a quarterback
that's pretty steady but he called
Hopkins arguably the best in the game is
that a compliment should he have gone
further as the guy that's on his team
should he have called in the best of the
game because actually being said
arguably the best of the game makes me
think that he's saying he's at that top
five yeah I think that's what he's
saying yeah he's not guy wish you went
harder right well we said he's the best
in the game yeah but I appreciate Andre
Johnson for keeping it 100 hey again
yeah I do too I mean I don't even know
if I know that's keeping a 100 I have a
hard time listening to guys like that
who were have common you know like Frank
Gore telling me LeSean McCoy he's the
best running back yeah no he's not I
know you're working out and that's
really cool but he's not the best just
because you're working out and you're
friends now and it's the same thing
there listen DeAndre Hopkins you know my
stance on that I think he's really good
I don't think he deserves to be in the
conversation with arguably the best in
the game not for me you don't think he's
of that top tier which you see is like
three guys I I think yes I think Odell
Julio and a B are in a class above a cut
above him and I would even say AJ greens
have cut above him as well DeAndre is
awesome but you know my stance on that I
understand he's had no quarterback play
and having that
people to help them out that arguments
really stronger I know it's a great it's
a great argument I get it but at the
same time you know I don't know and
that's what and so Madden has Adele's
quarterback been that amazing no and
that's well you know say that because
you know seven years ago the guy want a
Super Bowl so it's still like oh but
he's still awesome no yeah Madden has
Antonio Julio O'Dell and then Hopkins is
a 94 Odell's a 95 and then AJ greens
right behind that I also want to say
that we don't put Michael Thomas and all
this all the time but I could see Keenan
Allen passing some of those guys I think
it's absolutely disrespectful than Odell
is even close to DeAndre Hopkins on that
DeAndre Hopkins gets double-teamed
almost do you then Rodell speed almost
never like he never gets meanwhile
Odell's get covered yeah well I yeah
okay Odell speed is a 94 that'll agree
with Madden and Tyree kills is what a 98
let's see
right I thought we talked about it two
weeks today I'm tired killed where's
your ranking Tyreke is an 87 or all and
he's a 98 speed 87 overall yeah that's a
if Tyree killed below Brandon cooks to
Marius Thomas Adam Thielen a man and
we'll Sanders Julian Edelman Davante
Adams Golden Tate to uy Hilton Larry
Fitzgerald Mike Evans Alshon Jeffery
Stephon yeah that's wrong it's insane
right there are some guys when they step
on the field that you go holy [ __ ] he
could score at any time none of those
guys I listed are those people and Eric
Andre Hopkins I'm just sorry he might
get to jump ball in the end zone
I'm not joking you know me I have an
unbelievable play recall right you know
I can recall plays all the time numbers
stats DeAndre Hopkins touchdown against
Seattle last year but he caught the ball
over the middle and the middle is really
the only play I can ever remember him
having a huge Yaak play with the ball
innocence if you don't have yak then you
can't be talked about as one of the
greatest receivers in the league like
okay I know you can be talked to those
like one of the best like you're an
awesome receiver
yeah but the greatest can do something
with nothing you acknowledge that he
hasn't had the quarterback talent you
acknowledge that his ability to play the
ball in the air is great his
fundamentals his ability to know where
the side
line is toe-tapping that might be the
best in the league yes but if you're not
getting yards after catch you're not at
the level of the odells antonio's or
Julio's because that's what they do know
or AJ or Tyree kill yeah III would take
Tyree kill over DeAndre Hopkins man I
might be crazy but that would be my take
there oh you like that one you're
writing that down I don't I need you to
stop doing that big offseason whoa big
offseason next one
comparing somebody to a Hall of Famer to
possibly a future hall-of-famer do you
consider Darren Sproles to be a future
hall-of-famer do not know okay nevermind
Trey Burton talking about tarik Cohen
he said there's tons of talent on the
roster from last year guys like tarik
Cohen now I played with Darren Sproles
for four years and he and I love this he
goes and I would never compare any
player to Sproles which I love I would
never disrespect but Cohen is right up
there with his abilities without shifty
is and how fast he is
and those guys are extremely smart as
well right
what do you think is that accurate I did
very accurate I mean that's that's that
would be the pro player comparison to
rico know that and i would expect to
Rico and have an unbelievable year
because of that offense and he's gonna
be the Tyree kill in that office yes
he's gonna be the Tyree kill or the
Darren Sproles of that office it's gonna
be the same type of thing Sproles is an
amazing football player he's a legend we
talked about him a little the other day
because what he's second all-time
all-purpose yards is Sam Wright that
frickin height at that freakin height
with the punt return the kick return
played against him in college he's still
going strong and I talked to him pregame
Super Ball he said he wasn't gonna go
out on a CL so he was coming back but
phenomenal football player legend I
don't look at it as a future
hall-of-famer I don't and those guys I
feel like the league is finally gone
there's a place for these guys I can do
a lot and you know who I would say watch
out to be the nother guide like this
this year that people are sleeping on
that I think could be in the Rookie of
the Year convo when all said and done
pause I wanted to build up the suspense
who is it naheem Hines who's
the North Carolina State running back
who was like one of the fastest people
in the ACC yeah hole and I've heard good
things about him what team is he on he's
on the cults with your man Frank Reich
and they're gonna he's gonna be there
Darren Sproles that's interesting
because I was reading this Warren Sharpe
book which I'm gonna get into a little
bit cuz this man knows his [ __ ] right
but they were talking about everyone's
focusing on Marlin Mack nahi hai na heme
Hines is the guy to look interesting I
saw him in person of course with my
Notre Dame coverage last year North
Carolina State came to town yeah he is
that kind of guy I mean he's got a
rocket up his ass he was one of the
fastest people in college football punt
return you're looking at Frank Wright's
gonna run another similar offense that
throws the ball to the running back and
this could be the guy exactly so we just
gave a little fantasy advice tonight he
Minds he would be one of those guys I
would say watch out for Naeem Hines I
would expect him to be up like an Alvin
Kamara type year where we go you know
I'm not saying he's a good at between
the tackles runner yeah but where we go
oh this guy is one of the most explosive
offensive players of football he ran a
4-3 eighth of the combat okay he's got a
35 and a half inch vertical he's 5-8 198
so it was Tariq Khan's traybird and also
said he goes this offense and what
Nagy's doing is super exciting and it's
just it's exciting that like the NFL's
finally allowing really good offensive
minds to be head coaches and not forcing
them to be the mastermind with a
stubborn Jeff Fisher or a stubborn Ken
Whisenhunt right no earn your stripes
for 20 more years even though you've
tore up the league for five years and
you're 37 you're 37 that's too young we
can't give you the head coaching job no
they're qualified right let's do a bad
offseason before we get to your dad get
this out of the way I'll get big Phil on
the phone you tell me if he's okay first
thing I want to say about this LeSean
McCoy case a lot of people hitting us up
and went wow that was awkward you guys
were giving so many compliments to
LeSean McCoy and then this happened if
you've seen the story you know the story
he's being accused of punching his
girlfriend the pictures are disturbing
also all these other accusations he is
categorically denying it ruching
irritating Cognito came out and said he
he knows what happened
anyway he found having the CIA again
yeah just tell them the secret they've
been there following this I just want to
say this there's been a lot of cases
this summer that has made a lot of
people look dumb
the ruben foster case the gary and
connolly case this is what we're doing
it seems enough go we are gonna wait
until this plays out and then we're
gonna comment on we have to we have to
and we're not saying that either side
sounds more right we don't know and
that's because so we're just not going
to say anything you've seen idiots on
both sides of this argument and i've
seen it personally we've read about it
so yeah i don't know who to believe and
whatever happens that girl i feel
freaking awful and whoever did it
deserves to be punished I just I just I
don't wanna comment anymore no there's
nothing we can come I think we're just
we addressed it that's all there is to
do we'll see where it goes from this
thing it's a weird story
I mean I'll say it's gonna get weirder
well I mean it's it's his career is over
and always scares when you say I'm gonna
say this after he said we're not gonna
comment it's obvious that his career is
over if this goes back to him and they I
mean it's it's done so we'll see where
he's at that thirty point thirty year
age barrier plus like you don't take a
guy in the NFL after something like that
oh this is right this is gonna be Ray
Rice part two that picture is disgusting
yeah I didn't even see the picture you
don't you don't know it's gonna piss me
off
another Oh bad offseason Steve chyme GM
of the Arizona Cardinals gets a DUI on
July 4th what's interesting is when he
got arrested he told the officers that
he was the team's director of security
and lied about his role he also told the
police that he couldn't do any of the
physical components of the sobriety test
because of a pre-existing knee injury
which I don't drive a car but I would
totally steal that line that's actually
a pretty good line but you can't be
doing this but you kind of came out and
you texted me and said it seems like
they treated him kind of nice and this
and a player wouldn't get that III you
know yes I don't I don't I was I guess
what I'm a little annoyed with is the
language and some of the other things
that we see with players I like Steve
Kim I know he's a good guy yeah sure
I'll make my stand we all make mistakes
so this isn't like oh you're a bad
office guy we protect this is more about
just how it just seems to me a little
injustice
times okay first of all I never said
arrested it said cited did he get to go
home with somebody else I think I have
not seen taken so long because if it was
a player it wouldn't you're right and we
actually when Michael flew so a lot of
people comparing to this right Michael
Floyd it took nine days for his BAC
level to come out I think crime will
come out after this podcast but we saw
video what Michael's boys after like
that night I felt like Michael boy like
in the car being like were but nothing
of Steve crime has come out so that's
all I'm saying by that you're saying
that other players have not been granted
this kind of protection not at all and
and again I'm not I want to say it's
maybe it's that and and it's yeah it's
the fact that of course I think the
police officers have it out to get the
football players at times you get a
certain police officers just jealous or
mad or whatever it is but yeah it just
annoy me with the language like cited
for a DUI like that when I've read that
cited for a DUI it means like it sounds
like they let somebody else like hey
come here and pick him up we're gonna
give him a DUI but we're not gonna bring
him down to the station we're just we're
gonna cite we're gonna write up a ticket
and he's cited for a DUI but we're not
gonna bring him down there and put him
through the public embarrassment I just
I don't know that's all about I don't
know I'm sure that was my two cents
interesting noise me when it does you
know get played in that hit hit but to
soccer right right I guess my thing is
really like in this age with uber and
lyft and all that it's unbecoming the
day you're making millions of dollars
hire a driver and I'd be like that's
kind of like a big ask for people but
now it's like you're do you have like a
medium job taking uber like you get uber
anywhere pick up your car tomorrow it
makes no sense and even them over there
why we're on the Cardinals I'll tell you
the other thing that bothers me too like
Michael Bidwell coming out and talking
about the Supreme Court yes that's fine
with me it's just like when I read these
articles and I read likes comments
underneath things because I just like
allow me to see you actually go into the
comment I just want to look a little
because I look in these type of things
to go because I've seen the comments
when
come Jenkins and Chris long make these
political comma and they comment on
things yeah but he does they Michael
Bidwell the white owner doesn't get the
same responses that were the comments
they're kept here in the comments it
just it's nothing about stay in your
lane like I always see with football
players just talk about football blah
blah blah but you know the white owner
who's rich he can talk about whatever he
wants I guess it just bothers me as an
ex player and again it just shows that
there's a hypocrisy there in that
conversation like oh he's allowed to
talk about something outside his
business but players nope you can't do
that you're actually making me realize
something and I apologize for people
that don't like anthem talk but this is
what I was gonna say about the protest
that happens during the anthem right is
the owner can say I'm not talking about
politics I'm talking about my friend but
if the players go we're not talking
about the anthem we're talking about
police brutality that you know sorry
you're talking about it but Bidwell
you're talking about okay man
the last Obed offseason kind of just
came out the Pacman Jones fight in an
airport and apparently that Airport
employee has been got knocked the [ __ ]
out did he get arrested has he got a
resident the reason I'm okay talking
about this is because that Airport
employee totally took off his back port
at backpack and I ran at pac-man and you
made a comment because you know pac-man
well yeah I've texted back and forth
with pac-man because of YouTube he's
been our podcaster he was amazing times
I love pac-man but what did you say
about pac-man pac-man first of all
listen firs recklessness and all the
things that have happened in his
lifetime okay the one thing I'd know
about pac-man not only being around all
his friends that I was close to or he's
a part of pac-man circles well yeah yes
I knew some of you know yes his his
homies in a circle and some of those
dudes with the Titans it Titans right
because he was there right before I got
there right and I lost a lot of those
Titan players were friends with him and
the Titans had a lot of Texas players
that I was at Texas without you so it
all meshed together and with pac-man
I'll say this like he's not the type of
guy that's going to go around looking
for a fight he's gonna be he's a man's
man and the fact that he's not picking
fights or picking on anybody he's only
gonna get to that point if you've pushed
him and why you would push him I don't
know because
he has psycho in his eyes I mean that
respectively like he's one of those guys
where you go and if [ __ ] gets real
I want pack on my son well remember we
asked him right after Josh Sherman and
Odell fought what would you do if Odell
came at you and he's like incoming now a
lot of people would say well pac-man
does look at a fight look at the time he
like hit that woman about but in all
those cases the other person kind of hit
him first
yes I mean it says his actions
afterwards I can't stand by right and
I'm not saying he's been the model
citizen throughout time I understand
there's been some losses the opposite
many times yes but at the same time he
has looked like he's gotten his life
somewhat straightened out as far as that
stuff and yeah you watch the video first
of all the guy just looks like he starts
to fight it look back man tries to just
keep walking and kind of stay in his
Lane the guy also pushes the girl like
we're talking about like you know
domestic violence and all those things
he pushes the girl into pac-man and
pushes him the wall and I'm glad he got
his ass knocked out I enjoyed it
first of all you're crazy unless you're
in the UFC or you've been a wrestler at
some point you're stupid to start a
fight with a football player I just
realized something MBA players say this
all the time right that people come up
to them and say I'll bust your ass and
one on one because everyone thinks they
can take an NBA player NFL players they
look and they go I could beat your ass
you can't be like let's have a 40
competition let's have a catching balls
no it's like your physical I'm physical
I can beat you up yeah you're bigger
than pac-man sure yeah he's you final 11
to old 5 but can pack the power of a guy
that's 6-3 to 70 like whether he
squatted or benched in his prime he can
move that kind of weight and the reason
he runs for three when he was coming out
as he can put that kind of power into
the ground to make his body explode
right and that guy got hit on the chin
and collapsed and I'm gonna say he was
what four inches taller than pac-man if
not probably 40 pounds bigger if not
more and football players are stupid and
crazy and I was gonna say we always say
quarterbacks are the cockiest and most
athletic guys sometimes in the field and
pac-man is in the upper 5% of that
mindset he didn't even take his backpack
off he was like trying to take it off
and he's like the hell with it I'm just
gonna leave it on I'm a butt
his ass that way I'll be honest when he
squared up I was like if I was in front
of him that's what I would be like y'all
were just playing I'm just playing just
playing I mean and you can see it in his
eye to just in the TMZ video he's
fearless he didn't care you've told
stories a lot of times I've guys just
walk up to football players and try to
start fight they like Sean Rogers you
told that story that's it's crazy stupid
I don't get it and I do think it happens
sometimes is like the pac-man's of the
world to me is people who look at him
they go he's not as big as I thought I
don't like that dude I'm gonna talk
crack to him because he's not as big
that's like that's like would you start
a fight before you may whether because
he's smaller than you no no because that
shit's coming so fast oh my god all
right can we try and call your dad yeah
see if you responded yeah let's call
right so we're calling the cell phone
yeah let's call the cell phone let's do
they know the cell phone Nick do you
know the cell phone I might have to call
him again later yeah it's in his cell
phone all right so we're gonna call Phil
after that we're gonna go out of Sims
Stadium locks in and out of left go
field wow I'm gonna take you into some
statistics that I got from this awesome
football book that you might not think
are real and then we're gonna do fastest
40s of all time by position like that
yeah it'll be good ooh ring a ding ding
ding and ding ding ding we might get the
voicemail I probably are I think he's
[Music]
I'm in my car we just wanted to call
anyways cuz it was that time so we
called but when do you want to do this
you want to do later well let's see I'll
be home in no we got to do it now too
long no how long how long you be home
I'm gonna say at least 20 minutes or
more hey God do it now no let's call
them back no Phil can you do it now is
it ok yeah I give ya if you hear me OK
yes great all right fine let's start off
with this Phil how do I do it with a
ball you you were I just texted
Christopher you are the Aaron Judge a
wiffle ball you
two of the three longest well Alyssa
this Li they should have been home runs
but you stretched them into doubles your
son was saying that he had the biggest
most important hits the game yeah I did
yeah
yeah you know the game wasn't trimmed
into paper so the details are a little
foggy so I don't know all I know is it
was extra innings and we want you and my
you and my son had no mercy on little
kids and my daughter we have the little
kids on our team remember Phillip I
drafted Phillip and Charlotte so we
can't you can't use that against us okay
so my memory is not very good I made fun
of Adam the other day because I mean you
remember Adams first swing of the night
right
oh he felt about broke to her both
obliques his arms came out of joint yeah
and oh my god it was like he's swinging
he was like hang of it and Adam showed
some pretty good athletic ability I was
impressed yeah thank you so much yeah
Phil so there is a picture going around
Twitter right now of the old quarterback
Club with all you guys wearing these
like zebra Zumba pants and your hats and
all that stuff take take me to that
picture man how did all that happen with
the matching pants and all that stuff
well okay that was part of the
quarterback Club which was trying to get
away from the I'm not going to do the
whole thing the Union in other words to
get fair deals and endorsements for the
players and as we were taking that photo
I was standing there or city and
whatever I was doing I was embarrassed
because I didn't want to put those bans
on and I don't know if we got paid for
more why but man I've seen that picture
a thousand times and I hate it every
time yeah who do you think do you
remember like who actually wanted to
wear them and who was like man we look
stupid because it's like you and Marino
and Elway and Cunningham like all these
amazing guys
ya know I you know I don't know I guess
it didn't Bob you know listen we didn't
do it for free if I remember so that was
probably the main reason why everybody
said what the heck let's do it right
those you know you guys don't remember
they were kind of you know a lot of
people warm there for a while a lot
right I did I used to where I had the
red white and blue giant ones that I
used to wear around oh my god you
weren't where'd you wear them well I
mean around the house debated no I
didn't wear school I might have warm at
home time to school but wait wait so
when you first got like the quarterback
club though did you like the idea of
that I don't think I've ever asked you
that because I know I would be one that
would maybe be a hair tentative in my
playing days if I had your career
because I might not want to go hang out
with guys that I'd rather you know beat
their butts on a Sunday well change our
talks about each other come game day
right no but yeah look the quarterback
club went along included many many other
players besides quarterbacks and you
know really I don't know how to explain
them if I can display the right but
sponsors would go through the NFL
Players Association and the Players
Association would say here's how much
we'll give you to do this commercial
well you know that's just not their
rights all the players and this finally
got that way where oh you want me to be
in the commercial then come to me we
don't need another agent involved in
what's going on so it isn't up achieving
what it meant to meant to achieve more
freedom and more money and more really
just rights for the players when you
went to quarterback club stuff who did
you usually find yourself talking to or
hanging out with more than maybe some of
the other guys oh I did was seen it was
a John Elway for sure damn Reno like
have I not told you you know and the
ones that wanted to go play golf and
play for a lot of money that's not hung
out with the Vinny Testaverde was in
their line I told you about Mark Griffin
and we used to play but those that group
of guys
it was always okay you want to go
practice for the event or you want to
play golf yeah the hell with the event
let's go play golf and so so those
stories oh my god they were hilarious
John Elway was always though he was the
ringleader and I got to tell you this he
would say okay here's what we're gonna
play for and how we're gonna do it and
this and you just stand there and go oh
my gosh she's crazy
which I've told you before right but he
liked it and got it was a good golfer
but we had fun building so Phil we were
just talking about how sometimes people
in the public see NFL players and for
some reason they want to fight them
and I'm curious if anyone's ever tried
to fight you like a fan or something uh
no I don't remember anybody ever getting
this position where they wanted to fight
me so did I in public sometimes run into
people that would say the wrong thing oh
yes many times and you know I was pretty
good but every once in a while I would
say something really what's the word for
it really rough back to them in basic
gotta say how you like that in other
words what are you gonna do well I can
tell you that I'm not proud of it but
it's just I'm proud sometimes that line
is crossed so badly right you go come on
let this guy get away with this right I
can remember one incident okay and it
actually had to do with me but I
remember dad was ready to fight after I
blew the big 12 championship game
against Colorado my junior year I blew
it I threw three interceptions the first
half we lost because of me and we were a
better football team but we were walking
to the car after the game and you know
it was long after the game and I'd
already had the press conference and
blamed myself and done it all and I had
a lot of people heckling me sure and I
think I've told the story before because
I look down on my phone I had like 38
text messages some return to the Texas
had got my number and there but either
way I'm walking to the car and people
said stuff to me that and that was the
maddest I ever saw dad because dad was
ready to fight one of the guys that said
something to me that night yeah and I
remember me and my agent Steve Ross our
data dyes agent we kind of had a whole
dad back on that local back
yeah yeah I know sometimes being hell
packs a good thing you know saying so
yeah I remember that and you know but
that's that's part of sports hey did you
see what it would be like now oh my god
well did you see the video he probably
has to see that you need to see the
video of pac-man beaten beaten down some
idiot at this in an airport airport
security guy like was talking crap to
pac-man and like came at him and then
they started fighting in a real fight
yeah and pac-man knocked him to the
ground
Wow just happened yeah just happened
yeah when you get home wig open the
computer you'll see it oh come on man is
that he's a defensive back in the NFL
and he's in great shape and he's a
defensive back because he's fast as heck
and what was this guy like big he was he
was I'm gonna say he was like 6-3 6-4 to
32 35 he was pretty big and yeah he
chopped his ass down yeah that's exactly
what I would think you know I don't
think pac-man is any wilty flour no yeah
I would man like I said Phoebe's those
kind of guys I mean no no they quick or
strong fast you don't mess with them I
don't care if they're five foot eight or
six foot four Phil before we get you out
of here I just want to make sure that
we're still okay you still cool that I
didn't wear one of your bathing suits I
know that was a big issue for you well
well I had brand-new ones that have
never been worn before
it's weird but he was worried about your
balls I'm just that's all I'm gonna say
I mean come on you could have put the
brand-new ones on and you think I was
going to take him back no worried about
that even though he's touched 10 million
dirty things today and put his fingers
in his nose and all that but he was
worried about your clean washed no you
had new ones I thought he was gonna be
like I've worn my quota down Club the
90s hey listen I told you probably just
didn't want to show me a big ol hairy
ass
I don't know you know it was a lot of
fun it was I'm mad usually I do it
Christopher dosis I usually film all
those kind of games for a little bit
just so we can pitch it on anymore well
I know but get some Ida filament and get
everybody hitting and you know something
look back on like volleyball games that
we've had with my whole family up
whatever the games are you know softball
basketball games you doubt yeah well we
talked about this means I have to come
back again Phil so we'll do it another
time
well okay I won't underestimate your
athletic abilities very surprising and
that's all good take we'll see you all
right Begay that's right hey guys are
going to training camp wow man I
actually could not believe that when I
read that today I actually was like it
was it's the one day of the year I go
I'm glad I'm not playing football it's
like I have to go to training and that
was the worst day about being a football
player hey listen there were years I
would go we'd go so early to training
camp like right after the fourth of July
right and I'd go I mean it once I get to
August first I think mentally I can
survive but August first was today right
and I get there and oh my god with those
long years oh man
gosh alright enjoy some time off you've
earned it alright you guys be good
sneaky athletic ability sneaky abut I
got man that's what you do got packed in
there yes all right so out of sim
stadium not out of left go field you
found an article in Yahoo in which the
English soccer manager why you think
it's funny I look at Yahoo I just think
I just think I know that you're very
repetitive right so I know that Yahoo
must be like when you turn on your
computer that's the first thing it goes
on the first view yeah I don't know see
yah who they seem to be making money
don't they I guess so I don't know but
use it's an article about how the
England's English soccer manager
came to America and studied the NFL and
the MBA for better ideas on set-pieces
he said that it's like five to ten
percent of actual practices are spent on
corner kicks or free kicks when the ball
stopped and the rest is when they're
moving the goose but those are the big
plays yes thus far England seven of
their eleven goals have come from set
pieces do you want me to read some of
the things or do you want to expound no
no we read them first and then I'll just
some of some of the strategies that they
found one is a really good football
strategy when you're playing a zone
defense and there's two linebackers in a
zone then put three wide receivers there
and go three versus two if it's three
guys put four there and so that's what
they do if you watch their penalty kicks
or their corners in mainly their corners
if there's three guys blocking they're
put in four guys one guys getting which
is very odd I guess for soccer because
they would still put another guy in the
backside and make it three for three
yeah I heard this I was like this is a
revolutionary force ugh this is where I
want to go with it then also before set
pieces they huddle and they actually
talk about what they're gonna do and I
guess not a lot of teams do that they
just kind of go out there and figure it
out then the one that kind of added
there's like the delivery man for most
of the goals were wearing 12 and 18
which you know Aaron Rodgers Tom Brady
Peyton Manning kind of made sense but
those were some of the highlights of the
article and a lot of MBA stuff too but I
wanted to focus on the NFL's
yeah I just found it fascinating I think
for a number of reasons
I had read articles leading up to this
week about how the English coach had
gone all over and kind of met with
different football teams and then you
know swatching it you know I've seen you
know some of the commentators it's not
break down some of the things they've
done in the highlights and I've been
over man look at that it's like a little
Bunch route combination he got right
there to find that open but I do think
that sometimes that's where other sports
are lacking not only in our country and
our world but I've because I've had
these conversations with whether it was
the glaciers who owned Manchester United
whether I've been around my dad who's
been talking to Mark Cuban and people
like that and I've hear these
conversations where I feel like the
there they're amazed at the NFL coach
and how hard they grind and tried
become creative and find new ways to do
things and I don't think it's as
prevalent in the other sports and I
think it's one of the reasons NFL is so
special but yeah I mean just some of the
old norms that you see in soccer it
seems like it's like you can't break
some of these traditions and it's
interesting to see some outside the box
thinkers to go you know it I can do more
than just sit over here on the soccer
side on it here when we score a goal it
was a really cool because it was one
like they went to like this
Timberwolves Pacers game or something
like that and everybody was finding it
boring but the coach was like enthralled
because he was watching how people boxed
out for rebounds and how they set
screens like the English team apparently
sets back screens on corners and this
has not really happened before so that's
I'm like what exactly that's one reason
I was like I would run a back screen all
the time right like they're running like
a simple basketball stack out-of-bounds
play which I think you learn like your
second basketball practice as a kid and
the other teams are like oh wait you're
gonna go left and you're gonna go right
I'm like yeah it's a stack you've never
faced a stack that's where I was amazed
by it that's the only reason cuz like
you said I like it you just said I just
want to make why has it taken to 2018
for the oldest sport in the world to
figure out let me do this or that or try
this and I just what I really wanted to
do is give respect to NFL coaches that's
what I was kinda saying because I think
you know and say what's like that
they're anointed anointed I mean like
the coaching job of Manchester United
that used to coach Chelsea that's now a
man city was called like the Great Wall
right and I don't want to disrespect
their work but I can I can promise you
they're not grinding like Bill Belichick
or Kyle Shannon you know or doing that
kind of work where they're always trying
to find a way to be a new way to be
creative eight on three on two break or
whatever it is so I just I thought that
was fun well that's a perfect thing to
bring up so I want to give a little
shout out whenever someone brings cool
information I really want to honor it
Warren Sharpe put out his new football
preview it focuses a lot on betting and
gambling and fantasy but he really is he
goes through analytics it's NFL
analytics and him and Evan Silva so many
people give props to Evan Silva and I do
because they grind as hard watching the
NFL sometimes as the coaches and I went
through the beginning part of Warren's
book and I found like four or five
things that I found to be really
interesting things that a lot of NFL
teams do that after studying the
analytics he goes the really smart teams
aren't doing that the Patriots are in
doing that and here's a few so I'll
start off here number one he says teams
should throw two running backs on first
and ten all the time right he said the
two teams that do it the most England
the Patriots and the Saints shocker the
team that did it the least just 14% of
the time the Seahawks 21% was the league
average but he says on first and ten
it's such an advantage to get the ball
out in space to your running back that
that kind of you know it just makes too
much sense they're my playmates some of
the easiest completions you can get in
the smortest first and down first down
with your back out of the backfield
because you can teach your back to run
these certain routes against these
defenses you know that play base defense
or we're they're predictable and that
that first and 10 down series hundred
percent you can find out why Gruden
I mean 72 scat halfback choice what I
mean that's why you know Charlie Gardner
and he would calls out a first analyst
72 scat hat back choice what scan it
with you know 72 all go special right
we're okay we got a single safety yeah
we're gonna run her take a shot out of
her pose right but if we got too deep I
was gonna look to the right like I might
throw the tight end yeah even though the
play was only for the tailback and he
was my only guy I was gonna throw it to
that running backs and tight ends Warren
Sharpe says the league uses 11 personnel
which is one tight end one running back
69 percent of the time the league uses
12 and 21 personnel so either two
running backs and white and ten end or
two tight ends and one running back 49%
of the good teams all use 12 and 21 so
about that the the tight end running
backs have so much more success right
now in the NFL than wide receivers the
leaders in 12 Eagles Chiefs and Ravens
the leaders in 21 Patriots Niners and
bears
so Kyle Shanahan Josh McDaniels and Erie
Doug Peterson all focus on running backs
and tight end and the bear were the last
of the league oh god the Bears had
Dowell Logan Wright who was a disciple
of Shanahan - great - who believed in
that style but yes when I hear people on
TV go the spread offense is the way of
the future I go you're not really
watching the NFL like of course the
NFL's gonna steal a little something
from anything so yes there are some
spread concepts sure but we've talked
about this for two years right with
fullback bite
the good teams are using the fullback
and actually going back to the old days
again like we talked about with use
checker Devlin and the backside of the
backfield
you know the the Saints and what they do
with both basher so yes and it gives you
a chance to do more creative things
instead of just spread it out here's our
guys and there's only a few certain
amount of combinations we can do there
speaking of spread it out warren says
this and again shout out to warren sharp
check out his book the top three running
backs it redzone success getting in the
end zone are not power backs right why
because these running backs will think
that you're spreading it out the top
three McCaffrey Kamara and McKinnon most
successful percentage-wise at getting
into the end zone probably because
they're in the game they think they're
spreading it out and his whole take was
it's okay to go unconventional when you
put LeGarrette Blount or Jonathan
Stewart back there we know what you're
trying to do stop telling people you're
trying to you mentioned you don't know
they can go run who knows yes and again
the short completions are easier down
there Oh
instead of me trying to figure out a way
to get to my number-one receiver outside
house everybody knows I'm gonna go do oh
I have McCaffrey you can work on some
linebacker who has no business covering
and that's also just running the ball
that's not even a hazing that's just
running the ball that shows the threat
of the run absolutely opens it up here's
another one throw the ball on first down
stop running the ball on first down the
team that ran the most on first down
last year was the Buccaneers on first
down they ran at 67% of the time on
first and 10 and they only averaged
three that was last two years 3.6 yards
per carry
just not enough but when they passed on
first down they were averaging over
seven yards per attempt and it was
successful 67% of the time so it's at
but then he goes to this far Warren goes
so a lot of people let's say you throw
it on first and down first and 10 now
it's second and 10 he goes it's even
worse to then run it on second and 10 he
goes you're almost admitting defeat
teams run 54% of the time on sick on
second and 10 to olaphis I'm sorry teams
ran 54% of time on second and 10 a
success rate of only 28% the most
egregious team Buffalo they ran at 82
percent of the time on second and 10 and
the average 3.4 yards of carry the
Patriots on second and 10 ran 32 percent
of the time
Buffalo 80 82 Patriots 32 percent pagers
didn't go well we can find a way to get
a easy 5 yard completion and put
ourselves in third and 5 and just that's
our best shot yeah
so what Warren tells you it's very funny
yes the second and 10 throw the ball
right no [ __ ]
second and short run the ball he says
you're always gonna hear the announcer
say this they can do anything here on
second a shirt the whole playbooks open
let's take a shot you the top two teams
someone that goes into like I just want
to say two things like some of that has
to go into coaching too like we know
Sean McDermott with the bills they're
gonna play a certain style folks sure he
wants to play defense he wants to lose
the clock a little bit of Y as LaShawn
McCrory and he had a quarterback that he
apparently wasn't that fond of right so
that and then the other thing with Tampa
Bay and I'm not arguing against pectus
I'm just giving a little like Tampa Bay
I would think the first thing that came
to my mind would Dirk cutter was
everybody knows we're gonna always try
to pass because we don't have a good
running game and our offensive lines not
very good and he's really probably
trying to run just to keep a team on us
and also because they've had past
protection issues there as well yeah but
we know I'm not saying it's better I'm
just trying to say this every Bucks game
went like this pound pound pound pound
pound oh [ __ ] we're down 21 throw throw
throw throw throw where if you throw you
can set up the run you can open up the
field for a shitty offensive line oh
[ __ ]
longer the running on second in short
the two teams that do it the most
Patriots run 71% of the time and they
convert 82% first downs the Saints run
72% the time and they convert 80%
McDaniels and Peyton follow those guys
follow those guys they're not gonna make
you know there's no trick there and
those are the type of guys - yeah they
want to just get the first down
keep the clock to keep the the chains
moving yeah and what was my point gonna
be my point was gonna be those guys
wants
they won't settle for that they're not
gonna set they're gonna go are you
kidding me win if we can't get one yard
on second down then I don't want you to
be my office he'll challenge them yes so
there's a lot that goes into that but
that's pretty cool and that's amazing
because I feel like these are all things
we've been saying course and nany number
guy all the time where I look it up I
look it like this
it's my job to read [ __ ] like this to
educate the people that we talked to
Warren to someone that I followed for a
long time and I want to read what he
wrote about Kyle Shanahan because that
is our cuz I'm Kyle Shannon our favorite
coach now Kyle would be phenomenal in
all these amazing first down throw our
play-action passes he shoves it up your
butt every time of the place so Warren
had a segment called
make plays look like one another create
disguises here's what I wrote about Kyle
Shanahan loves to shift her motion to
disguise the formation he also loves to
use plays that look identical
far too often Teebs implement beautiful
game scripts see success and then don't
go back to those place teams need to go
back to use strategies that worked
earlier in the game and they also need
to have plays to use that look nearly
identical to those plays this allows
them to not only gain the benefit of a
great play that worked earlier they can
de see the defense with one of the plays
that gash them then when the defense
over commits to stopping the result a
totally different play is actually run
that to me is the Jaguars game in a
nutshell every play looked the same oh
by the way here's the full-back oh by
the way there's a tight end oh by the
way there's marques Goodwin right
exactly right well everything looks Joe
Staley said earlier in the office he's
exactly right and you know I think the
other thing that I find there is like
when he's talking about like plays ever
successful go back and use them again
that
it's a weird thing in the NFL like let's
just move on to the next one we
practiced all these this week so we
might as well run them why
like Belichick Paton Shanahan McVeigh
and they see something that you're not
stopping
they are gonna beat it to death until
you make an adjustment and then they're
gonna go off of that they're not they're
gonna be patient with it oh you're gonna
give us seven yards from this again okay
we'll do it again oh you're still in
this defense you're dumb okay we'll do
it again
mmm and why would you break away the
other teams are like I have my script
that I need to keep doing or like I'll
take you back to like Mike Martz Mike
Bart's had never ran the same plate
twice that was his thing in st. Louis it
was one of the things I know the
Patriots knew about him and that Super
Bowl they said if you see a play just
scrap it out of your brain it's not
coming again because he never repeat up
he had so many plays okay that's the
same but why why do you need that many
it doesn't make sense to me that's just
overload and then you're not becoming
great at one thing you're becoming good
at everything
and you have no great thing you don't
want Super Bowls by being good at
everything great at something right yeah
that was good I like that so you like
this that was amazing yes I check it out
2018 football preview Warren Sharpe I
want to give some credit stuff man his
dope
all right let's wrap it up with this and
it's all yeah I want you to guess the
top 40 times of all time for every
position because the name the list came
out I'm really excited about it where
did this come out I saw it on reddit
somewhere so shout out to Reddit you
guys the best were the kings of ready
yeah
bendrix watching everybody abeyance like
he's just so a proud papa fastest 40
time for a quarterback was who Michael
dick incorrect it was Robert Griffin the
third 4.41 I don't think Michael Vick
was documented you're right
I never stupid that was way too quick of
an answer I can't thought that out
fastest 40 time for a running back was
who CJ to K you're right Chris Johnson
okay play along at home I couldn't find
this out give me the top to wide
receiver speeds of all time who are
those two guys so I just wanna ask this
there's nobody on here before like 1980
is there really
there was always one there's no one on
here before 2008 okay so it's all recent
combat stuff so we're the two fastest 40
times for wide receivers mmm
damn I know let's see Tyree kills not in
there more I guess I mean one just
became the fastest of all time so like
that should be 100 the kid from the
Bengals John Ross right John Ross I
would have totally forgot that four to
two right the other one was Marcus
Goodwin oh four two seven four to seven
and I was like man he should have run a
faster fastest tight end to ever run the
40 having in 2010 seventh round pick
you're not gonna get it now go ahead
Texans Doren Dickerson Oh around a four
from Pittsburgh maybe I think it was yes
he was he was he was an athletic freaky
like a 42-inch vertical zu give me the
two fastest tackles to ever run the 40
am I gonna know them absolutely they're
they're two of the best tackles in the
NFL hey little one
one more guess you got that one wrong no
come on they're both all-stars both Pro
Bowlers all-pro blurs yeah both teams
went deep in the playoffs damn you're
really making me choke here acknowledge
the Eagles all right just tell me okay
first one Terron Armstead saints run a
471 but in there I never thought of him
and I said oh and then the
second-fastest was laying Johnson ran a
472 member laine Johnson was like an
undersized tight end when he first
started comment quarterback actually he
was a quarterback I mean his story when
the Eagles drafted him I was like look
at his movement this is incredible man
Terron Armstead I should have got that
he that he would be in that all right
give me that fastest Center to ever run
the 40 this one should be easy it's not
Travis Kelsey Kelsey yes this Jason
Kelsey around a 493 am yeah he runs fast
I'll never forget when we watched that
Washington film together
both pass and he ran 50 yards and outran
a cornerback to get to the spot to block
and that was awesome
all right defense let's go the the
fastest safeties to ever run the 40 I'm
really choking here mmm
one of them was drafted this year and
one of them was one of your favorite
players from two years ago one of them
was drafted this year yes and one of
them was from two years ago one of your
favorite players gosh okay doesn't
Landon Collins
now hold on this year this is this year
you're killing man he's he's fast fast
oh yes white boy from Penn State Troy
absolutely a key but had never thought
of that
ran a four three four woulda never the
other safety was one of your favorite
stopped cheating why cheat [ __ ] what
an [ __ ]
Wow you see it TJ green yeah from the
Indianapolis Colts also write a four
three four damn
let's go fastest corner backs to run the
40 so it's not you're not gonna get this
it's not beyond No
one of them is Jalen mirik Jaguars
corner from last year on a four to eight
okay and then Raiders drafted one in
2011 third round DeMarcus Van Dyke
around a 14 remember but I would never
got so that makes me realize safety guys
just if they're fast not that big of a
deal because I haven't heard of really
any of those case linebackers two
fastest linebackers one was drafted this
year one was drafted last year one was
drafted this year oh the kid from
Jermaine Jermaine Edwards incorrect
Shiki griffin ran a 438 the other
linebacker you hated his draft last year
gosh this is killing me yeah I hated his
draft when you talked about it last
podcast oh my gosh I'm flustered right
now
give me the team Browns Jabril Peppers
memory round with the linebackers that
one's [ __ ] alright let's just end
this here two fastest defensive end
forty times what happened in 2012 one
happened in 2007
tene alright so 2012 yes they're both
playing once playing a middle linebacker
now one's playing outside linebacker von
Miller's them alright once playing
inside linebacker yes Oh our Vic Beasley
[Music]
through serving though yes I got notice
the other one round of 25 Hasan Reddick
round of four five two and that were
your versus 40 here for his on Redick
it has to be thank you guys we love you
so much again we are only gonna have one
podcast next week it is gonna be a fan
mail bag it is jam-packed there are too
many follow Sims and left go on
Instagram I'm gonna use the new Q&A
feature Friday Saturday and answer as
many as I can so stay on a lookout for
that I'll try and answer as many
questions Sims won't be with me it'll be
more or less if you want to ask me some
stuff I don't care okay that sounds good
so we'll have one more and then by the
time we are back in here the following
week this entire studio is going to look
incredibly different decorations we
won't be in the gray hole of sadness
josh is looking at me I think josh is
going has this been okayed I've had
email responses back saying I could say
that so hopefully it happens for Sims
he's down homie for phil simms
appreciate your Braille venture could
say good evening and the lef koe says
holla holla holla holla holla holla
holla we will talk to you guys later
peace
enjoy your offseason whoa big offseason
see you guys later
hello Eli Manning what's going on what's
up man welcome to The Sims and Lefko
podcast only problem is Sims didn't make
it man snap it in dehydrated yeah got
you know what he needs
look at right there you go that's your
light so Eli we've already started I
just want to let you know that Chris
does refer to you as the greatest Giants
quarterback of all time and I just
wanted you to know that he says though
he says that with all seriousness oh
good don't thank you I will tell him
that indeed I could care less I am an
Eagles fan I still respect you I still
love you but I guess my question was
like when you guys want it kind of
sucked for me when the Eagles won did it
suck for you yeah you know it makes it
for a long offseason especially when you
when you see a couple of uh see a couple
of Eagles fans you know walking around
you know it's hard to say kind of
congratulations you know you kind of
want to you know you you understand what
they're going through a little bit
haven't haven't you know won a couple
and the excitement going on you know and
so you know it definitely you know makes
you we don't want to get back into that
position you you want to kind of have
that permanent smile on your face for
the whole you know six months off season
and and everything but you know kind of
looking forward to you know getting
getting the season started again so it
kind of you know kind of racist last
year and all the focus is back on this
year
Eli you know I was one of those four
year old kids giving you the finger I
think a lot you know yeah I was worried
about you know Eagles fans kind of being
offended but they're like yeah I think
they take pride in that ya know that's
me yeah he's a hundred percent he's
right on yeah we take that as like part
of our ranking we're number one it's
just a third finger compliment I
complimented you alright so we have a
thing around here called whoa big
offseason and it's things that capture
our attention that are either fun or
interesting and the number one thing
that's caught our attention is sake one
barclays legs and ass i have never seen
a human built like this and I was
curious what your reaction was the first
time you saw that set yeah no just yeah
I think wow as as you as you mentioned
it's it's whoa Eli it's whoa Wow sorry
you know his yeah his quads are like the
size of my waist and and a whole upper
body so I've never quite quite seen
anything like it I don't often stare in
another man's legs but in that case you
can't quite help it I know when you get
a rookie in and he can kind of exceed
expectations it really gives the team a
boost has he done that thus far well I
think he's done everything we asked him
to do and been impressive you know how
quick
he's picked up the offense and he's
performed well in practice I think with
you know four running backs though I
think it's hey well you know what can
you do once once the pads come on and
that's you know where those guys shine
hey can you make that first defender
miss can you get that extra yard can you
you know turn you know you know break
that long one and get a 60 yard run and
so you know that's where those you know
special running back said that that
ability that you know you know turned
that 5 or 6 yard gain into a 40 yard
gain and and so you know looking forward
to you know kind of seeing him in action
and seeing what he can do we love Odell
we believe he's one of the greatest wide
receivers of all time we can't wait for
him to sign a new contract and get paid
he deserves it you've played with really
good receivers you've been a part of the
game now for decades with your dad and
your brother and you've seen a lot where
do you put Oba O'Dell all-time in terms
of talent at wide receiver I mean from
from the talent wise hey he's right up
there you know with the best set on me
he can he can do it all
you know he's there's not a weakness in
his game his route running straight is
you know they'll play making ability you
know scoring touchdowns getting first
down short routes along routes he's got
it all now it's just you know obviously
to be you know considered one of the
great ones he's got to do it for a long
period of time and and obviously you
know he's gone according to his 50-year
last years tough man you know missing
most the season so it's just a matter of
you know of us getting on the same page
and you know continue to improve to get
better you know to you know we're
working his side you know win him you
know winning those you know those
battles more often and in making making
you know special things work on the
field
alright let's go into the future so put
on that seat belt we're taking the time
machine but I am now Adam left cone I'm
running the Hall of Fame
okay the it's we're well into the future
and I come to you and I said Eli I'm
editing your Hall of Fame video but we
only have one highlight that we can play
right before
you go up are you gonna pick David Tyree
or Manningham uh-huh you know hey I
think I think you know Todd the tie
replay is pretty special just you know
just because of all the circumstances
that went into it and kind of you know
kind of getting out of the getting out
of the sack and rolling out and and you
know David sketches well kind off the
helmet I think it's such a memorable
play for that year
you know going against undefeated
Patriots and the first Super Bowl so you
know that one's that one's always kind
of gives you gives you chill bumps every
time you see it it still does it's
incredible all right before I get to
Gatorade and they're the ones who have
set this up and I really appreciate them
there's been one other story line for
the Giants that has captivated our whoa
big offseason and that is some of the
quotes and stories about your backup
Davis Webb who you refer to as the
dragon I mean
Eli I'm reading these articles where he
can throw it better than anybody he's
got a playlist he's introducing you to
music he's got hundreds of binders it is
the summer of Davis Webb and I'm just
curious other than sticking dirt in his
mouth what can you tell us about the
dragon that could really like I need
this summer of Davis Webb to continue so
build the mythology of Davis Webb please
well I think I think is uh you know kind
of my favorite quote you know from from
practices or you know we're watching
watching the practice from the day
before just be you know he and I in the
film room and and you know he may you
know miss a throw you know it kind of
came out he'd do it you know a little a
little high or just you know receiver
off the hands and you know I mean I you
just just missed that whatever you know
well let's do it hard
let's do it hard and like that's okay as
long as you throw it hard got everything
everything is okay so that's the mindset
of Davis know I've been Davis has done
it sounds like a buddy cop relationship
it sounds like you two should be in like
lethal weapon side I think we could make
that we could make that work no we we
have a good good rapport and he worked
extremely hard he's got all the all
binders he wants his own printer in the
quarter bathroom so you can print
pictures and and you've never seen this
before right never seen to this extent
and and so he's making his own cutouts
of plays plays of other teams what
they're doing you know so how do you
guys focus on you know learning learning
these protections and our own protection
our own plays a little bit but you know
he works extremely hard he's into it and
so it's good it's good to see you know
yeah anything I'd asked for him to break
down a film break down a team or look at
this blitz I mean he comes with you no
more more than more information than I
asked for that's all and if you want to
just tell me I'll keep a private while
you call him dragon I would love to know
I don't think we have enough time I
think to deep too many too many reasons
all right what are you doing with
Gatorade and the Gatorade beat the heat
can yeah so this is a Gatorade and
they're there beat the heat program
which really you know kind of educates
athletes across all sports about the
importance of hydration especially
during these hot summer months so today
out here is a little football camp going
on it's 90 degrees these kids are
running around getting ready for for
two-a-days and their summer a you know
some are all season training camp and
just talking the importance to staying
hydrated and that's not not just during
practice that's right when you wake up
it's getting your electrolytes you know
so you retain your fluids drinking lots
of Gatorade you know just not only for
health reasons just to say you know stay
healthy the number one important reason
but also just to keep your performance
high and so you are performing on the
field and you could do it every day it's
not just a one day thing it's it's kind
of a commitment to doing it every day
and staying staying hydrated you know
and beating the heat that's awesome hey
you know what I need you to beat the
Eagles because they're 16 and 4 against
you in the last 20 games my men we got
to get it going hey and from one Eagles
fan to the greatest Giants quarterback
of all time I do this out of all respect
I am giving you the finger right now
that's what Philadelphia fans should do
so I hope you're appreciating this I do
appreciate that you're rotting so much
Eli you're the man Gatorade check them
out have a great offseason man stay
healthy good luck next season all right
thanks so much appreciate you man